à faire un petit bisou belge je vais
dire des noms de gens belge et tu vas me
dire comme ça ce que j'en pense baudoin
le roi baudoin écoute ceci peut pas si
mal moi je sais très bien dans un pays
comme la belgique où il ya vraiment un
vrai un vrai racisme est une vraie
tendance au fascisme quand même à
l'extrême droite dans toute son horreur
c'est un type qui tous les ans à la noël
quand il vient faire son speech et bien
il parle des 10 millions les en les
intégrant en l'exempt faire partie du
pays et je trouve que c'est pas mal
en ces temps dit il ya peu de gens qui
prennent des dispositions fabiola on a
l'air bien mais qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent que c'est pas vrai chocolat
belge mais moi non plus une autre belge
christine ockrent un jeu préfet raymond
devos
oui jacques brel
j'aime bien même beaucoup score qu'à des
champions si tu les connais les chansons
de jacques brel sens comment ou laquelle
je veux chanter
est ce que je pourrais être champion le
pays au nom de cela je pourrais tu es
chanter la plus connue même qui te parle
on peut oublier tout peut s'oublier
ça sent fille déjà oublié le temps des
malentendus et de temps peintures
à savoir comment oublier ses seuls qui
tuait sa foi un coup de pourvoir le col
du bonheur d'un petit pain ne me quitte
pas même si tu vas me quitte pas